when you read the script it's like
extreme close-up of Chris Evans as guns
are you like that's what it says that's
what it says yeah it said zoom in on the
bicep you're just like oh great now I've
gotta hit the gym even more yeah when
you're filming those movies you try and
get as fit as you can by the time you
start and I actually messed up my arm
don't I really did
sorry Chris but worth it we loved his
biceps but what's his favorite female
body part he reveals all too on a ferris
on her podcast I am I'm way way way more
than ass man you know I like butts you
gotta understand we do on a podcast in
Ana's living room and then of course you
know don't you guys just know how to
cherry-pick those lines and blast them
on the head lines don't you I had
nothing why oh it's you you are the
enemy god these things get picked up and
they run forever and the internet
doesn't die and no I'll just I'll keep
jamming my foot in my mouth I can't
don't you worry
of course Chris is a bachelor with no
kids but a lot of the father's in
Captain America Civil War have to be
among the coolest dad ever what do your
kids think about you being a superhero
my daughter who is six she talks about
it a lot and she draws pictures of
ant-man
a lot yeah it's really sweet my daughter
she was nearly three at the end of the
day when I took it up she threw a first
tantrum
I want purple daddy at 21 and 19 I think
they're like Betty's rights check that's
that's what daddy does